we're living at a pivotal point in human
history almost two centuries we have
relied on coal and then oil then more
recently on natural gas so now we have
to make the transition to a new energy
system it's going to be as fundamental
as the changes that took place during
the first Industrial Revolution so I
think it's critically important for a
good university with an international
footprint to take these issues on in a
serious way
India is home to the second largest
population in the world it's going to be
the country with the largest set of
young people is many of us think that
this is a country where a lot of the
world's economic growth is going to come
in the future
we are likely to also see many of the
cost special environment being
increasingly borne by India in the next
two decades and for all these reasons
India becomes an incredibly important
player when we start thinking about how
do we protect human health and how do we
deal with climate change the
transportation sector faces really
substantial challenges in terms of
transitioning to a low GHG future and we
don't know what that future is going to
look like but I think that the biofuels
could play a potentially of an important
role especially an important role in the
transition so the challenge that we're
looking at in our project is how to
facilitate low GHG biofuels and their
use in the transportation sector if
we're used to thinking about climate
change in terms of averages right global
warming is the phrase but increasingly
we're finding evidence to believe that
actually it's the change part of climate
change that matters more than the
warming part of global warming most of
the damages come from a few extreme
events climate change is an economic
competitiveness issue that it will
affect economic growth the economic
aspects of climate change are crucial
and thinking through right what are the
costs and benefits how much should we as
a society be willing to invest in
mitigating greenhouse gas emissions most
scientists will be strongly that co2 is
altering our Earth's system what the
artificial leaf does is it stores
renewable energy when in sunlight in the
form of the fuel
you just drop it in water and sunlight
hits it but not one side comes hydrogen
enough the other side comes out to them
so it really is like a leaf it doesn't
have years and it's not a heavily
engineered system instead of having a
gas station you could have a solar gas
station one of the main problems that we
see is that these extreme heat events
really pose a threat to some of the
people living in buildings that are not
designed to deal with these temperature
levels so what we want to do with our
research is use sensors that
characterize indoor environmental
quality and biometrics on people so we
can also think of ways of recommending
changes to the built environment and
behavioral choices that people can do to
adapt better to these conditions we use
an enormous amount of oil pesticides
fertilizers water other resources to
make food and when we're throwing away
somewhere around 40% of that food that
means 40% of those inputs are just being
wasted but one of the big areas we've
worked on is around date label sell-by
used by enjoy by born on packed on which
caused many many people to throw
something away because they think it's
gonna be unsafe when in fact it has
nothing to do with safety and then on
the back end of that the food that winds
up in landfills actually is a huge
contributor of methane emissions which
is a really potent greenhouse gas
Harvard important role in climate
changes it has all the pieces so you
have the government piece the policy
piece blob he's the business piece but
the piece that's most exciting for me is
the solution piece which is the science
engineering discovery piece so when you
get to Harvard they have the full card
deck the entire debate on climate change
has often focused on questions relating
to what are the facts but they're more
importantly even if you want to address
this problem how do we go about doing it
understanding how in countries which are
seeing fast growth but have weak
institutions how you can implement good
policies is to think about how do you
change human behavior by giving them
incentives and getting an answer to this
implementation issue that we're going to
be critical in implementing any time it
change policies we're trying to make
policy on fifty to a hundred year
timescale something that we really
haven't done before as a civilization
and so being able to clarify even small
patches right up the Shroud of
uncertainty that surrounds this issue is
a hugely valuable task that places like
Harvard are uniquely well positioned to
tap